there are two DLCs arriving for Dark
Souls 3 and there are two very
intriguing unfinished plot lines that
still remain in the game and these two
plot lines they directly oppose one
another one in the previous video was a
tale of lon door and this is a tale of
the Angels that was a story of a dark
Wraith locked in the deepest depths and
this is a story of an angel locked in a
Cell in the tallest tower a story about
usurping the fire and a story about
linking it a story of calf and frampt of
gods and men
Masaki the game's creator he takes a lot
of inspiration from the manga series
berserk and one of the most powerful
themes in berserk that I don't see a lot
of people talking about is the
displacement of good and evil in themes
of light and dark for example good is
seen in the black swordsman and his
darkness and evil is seen in the angels
and their light similarly in souls
mankind were the ones with the dark
souls and even though the gods are
associated with fire and light these
gods are dedicated to selfishly keeping
themselves in power at the expense of
all humanity so keep this in mind as we
talk about the angels of Dark Souls 3
because I wouldn't be surprised if
Guinevere were a boss in the DLC but
we'll get to that the Angelica faith has
its roots in lothric where Queen
Guinevere is said to have raised several
heavenly children the lothric bloodline
has always been devoted to the linking
of the fire obsessed with creating a
worthy heir and their ruler currently
appears to be the young prince lothric
and engraved upon the doors leading to
his chambers are three figures that
represent the three pillars of power
that uphold his rule first the high
priestess whose Duty it is to feed and
care for the noble children essentially
she's their wet nurse and it's clear
that these women groomed the princes for
a role in the linking of the fire
they're not your traditional wet nurse
for one of them begs us to convince
lothric to follow his duty as a lord and
the other to sit directly within the
file link shrines the second pillar is
the knight responsible for the defense
of the kingdom the lothric Knights were
allowed to tend to the wyverns and fight
alongside them as these dragons also
belong as a symbol of wather ik and the
third pillar the scholar who is master
of the grand archives of knowledge and
of the three the scholars seemed the
most influential especially to our young
lord lothric who
was frail and disinclined to knighthood
the grand archives and the lothric
bloodline
they also rose together and the first of
the scholars was alleged to be a private
mentor to the royal prince and here is
where the story gets really fascinating
because this private mentor first of the
scholars he doubted the linking of the
fire and it's clear that whoever he is
he planted thoughts of rebellion into
the young Lords mind so these were the
three accepted pillars of the Kings rule
the High Priestess the knight and the
scholar but there was one more pillar
who serves lothric on the fringes and in
the shadows the hunters a fourth pillar
of rule who punished the king's enemies
in ways that the Kings three pillars
cannot these were highly adept warriors
and they were known for wielding paired
weapons and some was so proficient in
their duty that they even managed to
serve successive generations of Kings
these hunters specifically became known
as the Kings black hand and for
generations these hunters served the
lauric bloodline and for generations
their rule was clearly prosperous
however the pillars of lothric are
crumbling when we arrived and Prince
lothric refuses to link the fire so bear
with me once I have the groundwork laid
we can get into the really interesting
angels stuff so in Dark Souls 1 we were
introduced to Guinevere who was first
born daughter of wind the man who linked
the fire and this illusion of Guinevere
at least says this pleased father's role
thou should assume and inherit if the
fire of our world in lothric now
Guinevere is heavily implied to be the
queen of lothric married to King a Cyrus
and revered as a goddess of fertility
and bounty and living up to that title
she became a wife and a mother who
raised several angelic children and just
like in Dark Souls 1 she's pushing on
to link the fire she's one of those
goddesses that uses us and the lothric
bloodline her children they were
obsessed with creating a worthy heir and
there's a lot more evidence of her
influence in pushing undead and done
kindled to link the fire the path to the
kiln itself is hidden behind the queen's
castle and unconditionally associated
with win aveer the queen even placed a
powerful artifact in a coffin that she
thought a future and kindled could
profit from and yet the castle is in
chaos her husband has gone mad and her
noble children are scattered and defined
so the Queen does what she did in Dark
Souls 1 she leaves the kingdom and we
when we go through it we're left to
piece together how exactly this Kingdom
collapsed from the children her children
that remain Prince Lorien and his
younger brother lothric remain in the
throne room of their castle implying
that they were the ones in power as
their rule collapsed Prince lothric is
described as the last hope of his line
for linking the fire but lothric went
against his duty and against Guinevere's
legacy and refused to link the fire when
you approach their chambers take notice
of this stretch leading up to it all the
Knights are facing outwards barricades
are raised and sure this could mean that
they're protecting him from us the
unconnected lothric from the angels and
their winged knights so this is my
favorite part of the script at the
tallest point of the grand archives
hangs this enormous cage
within is a corpse white feathers and
the miracle divine pillars of light
which was a miracle of Gertrude named
the heavenly daughter and in Japanese
the Angels daughter Gertrude is said by
many to be the Queen's child
this miracle brings down divine pillars
of light and it was told to go Trude
when she was visited by an angel despite
losing her sight and her voice you know
she was blind and mute Gertrude was
still determined to record this tale of
the Angels visit somehow this blind mute
girl wrote down what she heard in a
fragmentary scroll and in Dark Souls 3
there's this huge tradition of placing
great faith in the words of the blind so
somehow despite being impossible for
ordinary men to decipher this tale of
the angel became the foundation of the
angelic faith of lothric so now a
question is what does the angelic faith
of lothric stand for what do they
represent and it's my belief that all
angelic references are related to the
way of white which was a human faith of
clerics paladin's and pilgrims who are
supporters of the linking of the fire
and the gods let me provide some
evidence as he traveled through the
world of Dark Souls 3 the sharp observer
would have realized that there are a lot
of angelic references and I'll name five
and convince you of their relationship
to the kingdom of Warrick so one the
statues in Apollo 3 are winged and one
set of wings even belongs to a depiction
of a primordial serpent in the last
episode we talked about the mention of
CAF and on the flipside
wouldn't it be fitting for frampt who
was this serpent in Dark Souls 1 who was
a huge advocate for the linking of the
fire wouldn't it make sense for him to
be a manipulating force in lothric a
rule known for the linking of the fire
secondly in the Cathedral of the deep
you see statues of winged men and indeed
the archdeacon's of the deep wear robes
denoting the highest rank in the way of
white and originally this order was not
evil they were devoted to tending to the
flame and in this video we assumed that
this meant that they were tending to the
flame of oldrich when he became a lord
of
however when Aldridge rose from the dead
this order of the way of white became
corrupted by his influence and they
abandoned their service to the gods you
see this in the statue the angels this
way of white cleric it's overcome by
Aldrich's filth third the silver knight
helps our wind and indeed the silver
Knights in particular are loyal to the
old royal family even protecting this
family's Manor long after it was
abandoned in particular though the
silver knight shield has the blessing of
their goddess Quinnie veer upon it even
to this day and Guinevere is
intrinsically related to the Angels four
of her children Gertrude wather ik
Lorien and Rosaria they have some link
to white feathers on Gertrude's cage
floor Lorex floor and shot from the by
dint of the mangrove casters and
Gertrude's description actually calls
her the angels daughter in Japanese not
just a heavenly daughter
these children are linked to Guinevere
and they're linked to the Angels and
finally when I look at these beheaded
statues in lower lothric I think of
another reference to beheading
you know we place the heads of the lords
of cinder their cinders atop their
thrones to satiate the fire linking
ritual and I think these statues are a
symbol of self-sacrifice to the linking
of the fire look at the way they cut
their own throats and hold their own
heads willingly in their hands when
these were built lothric was known for
the linking of the fire and I think
these represent that and the final
reference to be heading to the way of
white are the winged executioner's who
swore themselves to the angels and their
set reveals the most curious part of
this story it says that worship of these
divine messengers is heresy in lothric
and unrecognized by any of the three
pillars of rule in an attic in the
behind an illusory wall lies a giant
portrait of a winged messenger and a
sacred shield shield known as sorceress
Bain and an heirloom of the way of white
now with all the connections we just
made to the Angels being supportive of
the linking of the fire the statues the
helmets the feathers whywould lauric
call it heresy why build statues to
something heretical and the only
solution I can come up with is that it
became heresy when lothric refused to
link the fire it is said that this is
why gertrude the heavenly daughter was
imprisoned in the lofty cell of the
grand archives her faith previously
accepted must have become heresy when
Prince lothric took over for he was
positioned directly against it and
remember the first of the scholars was
private mentor to Prince lothric and of
the three pillars the scholars are
closest to the prince and it is the
scholars themselves who tampered with
the sacred chime of Gertrude allowing
her blessed item to be used for their
own ends and in a huge way the scholars
were behind Lorex refusal to link the
fire and in turn Lorex
persecution of the angels it's no wonder
that Guinevere fled the kingdom and one
of the earliest law questions I ever had
in Dark Souls 3
you might remember it was why an
executioner was patrolling a burning
courtyard full of headless Knights why
this was the scene of a battle and now I
think I know why I think Gertrude's
imprisonment was the beginning of a
conflict between the crown and the
angels lothric Knights and winged
knights never fight together and both
lower and upper lothric have corpses
from each side within the castle itself
additionally the assassins close to the
crown prince the black hand one of their
rings is on the roof where
three fully ascended golden-winged
Knights guards the entrance to go Trude
sell the King's Black Hand assassin
loyal to Prince lothric was here and he
was killed so now we come to the part
where the answer is very much up to you
his Gertrude the corpse in the cell
perhaps killed by the Kings black hand
or simply dead of starvation or his
gertrude cell door opened because she
escaped flown away by one of the wings
knights or his Gertrude alive and in
game is she related to this mangram
bizarrely placed on the rafters below
her cell is Gertrude Rosario if I'm not
mistaken the first one to come up with
this theory was Reddit user deleted away
who in particular reminded me of the
deacons relationship to the way of white
of Saint Klimt and also of the dark
Wraith far below and the angel up above
I'm hugely thankful that he reminded me
of these connections because it's become
a really important part of the story so
why is this man grub here is Gertrude
Rosario the man grubs are creatures that
have been reborn through Rosario mother
of rebirth located in the Cathedral of
the deep and worshiped by some as a
goddess
Rosario's fingers collects tongues in
her name some do it to be reborn indeed
if you hand in more than five you're
said to run the risk of turning into a
man grub but some simply give her
tongues to help comfort their voiceless
goddess for Rosario mother of rebirth
was robbed of her tongue by her
firstborn and has been waiting for their
return ever since we talked earlier
about how the archdeacon's of the deep
are high-ranking within the way of white
and we've established the way of white
are devoted to the servitude of the gods
and their age of fire so it makes sense
that the Cathedral of the deep would
have been a safe place for Gertrude to
escape to or at least why a daughter of
Guinevere could reside in this place
even if you don't believe that Gertrude
is Rosario and I do have my doubts it's
incredibly likely that Rosario is a
daughter of Guinevere given
the feathers and given the fact that she
has one of Guinevere's miracles as a
part of her soul so you don't have to
believe that Gertrude is Rosaria but
Rosaria is here for a reason and as we
know the Deacons of the deep became
completely corrupted by Aldrich's
influence in fact all three archdeacon's
are characterized by an abandonment of
their duty in the way of white one in
particular though he was originally
tasked with attending to Rosaria mother
of rebirth
his name was Saint Klimt and we hear
about him from his weapon the Saints by
dn't which he eventually discarded this
by dn't was a holy symbol which draws
upon faith you see this biden's actually
when man grabbed Castor's attack you
this exact shape materializes leaving
behind a trail of white feathers
assumedly this is a symbol of Clint's
relationship with Rosaria through the by
dn't and rosaria's connection to the way
of white through the feathers or by now
if you believe this theory about her
being Gertrude maybe I should be calling
Rosaria Gertrude however like the other
deacons abandoning their duty to the
linking of the fire Klimt discarded this
weapon and put his faith behind him so
if you believe the theory that Gertrude
was Rosario then she was forced out of
lothric because the angelic faith was
lost there and after taking the name
Rosario in her new refuge the Cathedral
of the deep she was trapped there too
once the Deacons became corrupted by the
deep so again the way of white and the
angels would have been cast out of la3
essentially so there might still have
been refuge in the Cathedral of the deep
where the Deacons still served the way
of white so that makes sense for Rosario
or Gertrude to be placed there but after
they turned to Aldrich
Rosario would be in trouble and you sort
of see that when you look outside her
chambers there are man grubs investing
the Cathedral and they're defending her
they're staked to the walls maybe in
defense of their goddess and there are
bars that are bent outwards and a lot of
sludge around the area so maybe Aldrich
tried to get in there
when he was on his way out so this
entire part about Gertrude being Rosaria
it's a fantastic theory and one of the
best in the series because of all the
little circumstantial pieces of evidence
even if I'm not totally convinced and it
isn't perfect it doesn't explain the
corpse in the cage or why Rosaria
supposedly an angel instructs her
followers to invade and pillage on the
other hand Gertrude
taught her followers bountiful light and
rosaria's soul teaches us bountiful
sunlight a more powerful version of the
same spell if we get more information in
the DLC which I think we will we'll come
back to this topic but for now the only
thing that matters is what do you think
it's been a while since the way of white
surfaced in such a powerful way in Dark
Souls 1 they sent an undead paladin to
fetch the rite of kindling deep within
the catacombs and it was the start of a
convenient way of disposing of undead
within their ranks and they continued to
send their undead to lordran on this
quest convincing them it was a holy
pilgrimage you know if they succeed if
they brought back the rite of kindling
then great but if they failed then the
way of white just disposed of some
undead and in Dark Souls 3 the way of
white continues to use humans for
kindling and assuming the way of white
are the angels they're presented as
angelic as good as holy but the reality
is that them and Guinevere likely at
their head or anything but they've been
using humanity for kindling and I think
we'll be getting the chance for a little
bit of revenge soon the day before I
finished this script user Raven beta
underscore 1 1 4 made a thread on reddit
with evidence that Guinevere will be in
the DLC citing an unused boss track that
sounds very much like Guinevere's theme
from tarsals 1 have a listen
I'd say they're onto something here and
even if it's not Guinevere
it could be someone related to her so
with Gamescom coming up I expect we'll
be hearing about DLC soon but what will
it be about the hollows of lund or the
angels of lothric or will I be
pleasantly surprised and it will be
something else entirely
thanks for watching this video and thank
you to those who support me on patreon
in the description I'm going to leave a
link to tons of other theories and some
are quite different to mine on the
nature of the angels in Dark Souls 3 so
read up and come to your own conclusions
thanks for watching guys see you next
time